okay
i think um it's time for us to start
um we have enough number of participants
okay i'm so honored to um
have gyeongsu today here as a speaker
of today's data driven physical
simulation
seminar and pyongsu
is a doctoral student joint structural
student
at computer graphics lab at utah stuart
and disney research studios i
i didn't i i didn't know uh the disney
research studio was taking a student
maybe can say some something about it
but his research is focusing on
data driven approach in graphic
applications but i think his methodology
is closely related to many projects
in lawrence livermore so i think it will
be
a great interest to many of you
so no further dues uh here is
so can i start yes
so hi everyone and thanks for the
introduction yongsu and uh thanks
also thanks for coming to this talk
today everyone
so i'm yongsu uh as i said uh as young
said i'm a joint phd student at computer
graphics live at etheric and a digital
research studio
my research mainly focuses on deep
learning methods for
art directable fluid simulations and i'd
like to introduce some of our
recent works in in this talk
so physically based animation techniques
progressed to a mature state
over the last 25 years like water smoke
fracture or quality with qualifications
even pizza have been successfully
simulated
which are impressive realistic
simulations that have been widely used
in
digital content creation
so i'd like to highlight the traditional
challenges in physics-based simulation
in computer graphics area
so for visual effect artists it is
necessary to have a physically plausible
but computational efficient and also
artractable simulation tool
at the same time so in graphics we
usually focus on its feature
appearance so it's allowed to sacrifice
accuracy to some
extent for performance and
controllability
so as we believe that deep learning
methods can provide faster
realistic and more controllable
simulations
so i'd like to show some notable related
works first
so back in 2015 louvre and soyun
proposed the first
machine learning approach to replace
particle-based fluid solver
building uh impressive speedups
so it can handle more than millions of
particles in real time
for simulating different types of
materials i can
viscous fluid here
and sand for example
so they just say this in our workstation
with the decent gpu but yeah it's pretty
fast
and then this project project was a
collaboration of our group and
computer vision group at eta trig and
the authors created a startup for
developing this idea further
and similarly thompson error employed
convolution neural networks for speeding
up the pressure server solution on
grid-based
fluid simulations and my colleague
stefan proposed the latent space flit
servers with auto encoders and
lstm architectures for time integration
in low dimensional latent space
on the other hand other approaches try
to enhance final visual quality of given
simulations
that are computed on course resolutions
true and theory introduced the
patch-based data-driven method for
turbulence synthesis and ammeter
proposed a neural net architecture for
augmenting liquid splash models
and theater introduced the super
resolution method for flow data
they used a generative adversary
networks to get highly detailed and
temporally coherent flow structures
and recently we proposed a new paradigm
called
fluid stylization so basically we adopt
the neurostyle transfer method to
transfer
style of to the images to 3d fluids
afterwards it allows to stylize
smoke with intricate motifs
and colorization as well
and look at stylization
another trend in this field is a
differential physics simulators
so by holding differentiability on every
part of the simulation
it is able to optimize its motion
controller or
initial parameter settings to achieve a
target state after certain time frames
so it can be coupled with deep learning
architectures and
provide a natural interface for
image-based applications
some works focus on parametrized base of
fluid simulations
resulting from a generative model this
generative model allows us to get a
spontaneous response in a reduced space
for
prediction or controlling certain
quantities
for instance metanator proposed a data
driven method for
predicting flows around parametrized 3d
shapes
and parental error introduced an
approach for blending and synthesis of
deformation fuel
for real-time liquid drop simulations
so i'd like to introduce our work again
so our work is classified as a
generative model
since we generate affiliate data from a
set of radius dominating parameters like
source position
equal speed up smoke and time
the title of this work is the fluids a
generative
network for parametrized fluid
simulations and this work uh
was the result of collaboration between
ethereum technical university of munich
and pixar and presented at the
eurographics 2019.
so in this paper we proposed the first
generative neural network that fully
constructs
dynamic eulerian fluid simulation
velocities from a set of
reduced parameters once our network is
trained
we are able able to achieve up to 700
times
performance speedups compared with
underlying cpu servers
and our approach enables interpolation
between
different samples across widely
different parameters
while still keeping a reduced memory
footprint
our method provides a powerful
compression algorithm for fluid velocity
fields
lastly we describe a novel
latent space integrator for complex
parameterization
to illustrate the capability of our
approach
we show a reconstruction example
compared against the ground truth
simulation
our cnn reconstructed simulation shows
possible flow reconstruction
even though our generative network is
trained on discrete number of examples
it can produce physically plausible
interpolations which is not present
in the training data set the simulation
shown in the middle
example is not on the original data set
but we can still interpolate for an
intermediate buoyancy value which will
the smoke plume line between
two discrete samples here you can see
the
bloom line and this is possible since
cnns can naturally learn a non-linear
interpolations
between the sets of input parameters
so now i'm going to detail how our
general tip model works
firstly i would like to highlight that
the image data set and velocity fields
are inherently
different setup a phase dataset
possesses eigenshifts
while a spatially and temporally varying
velocity data doesn't on the right side
histogram plots of each dataset shows
the difference in statistical features
more clearly
and we can see that velocity datasets
have more complex distributions in mean
max mean and standard deviations
therefore we cannot train velocity-based
generative architectures with
off-the-shelf image-based metrics and
i'm going to explain the modifications
that we needed to
doing in order to implement our fluid
generative cnn
so these modifications can be separated
into three parts
data set generation cnn architecture and
employed loss functions
and firstly i'm going to explain how we
generate our data sets
so the incompressible naviestos
equations consist of momentum and mass
conservation laws
and we had several options between
output data fields such as density
velocity pressure and stream function in
which we can see
on the videos from left to right
because of efficiency and physical
physical constraint
we chose velocity fields as our training
data set
so here we show videos of several
examples since
using our one of our training data sets
so in this example we vary the inflow
velocity
and the buoyancy of a smoke source
traveling horizontally
on an open container so there are five
inflow velocities three buoyancy values
and
250 time frames yielding 3750
unique velocity frames as training data
sets
due to the inherent nonlinear nature of
the navistos equations
these three priorities already created a
collection of widely different
simulations
so going back to the overview of our
approach
i'm gonna detail next our architecture
so in our first attempts we tried
several unsupervised
architectures to reconstruct fluid
velocities
from a laden space representation
for instance bcgan acgaem
introspective gan and and so on
but you know they all failed in my
attempts
it's because of our field attempts and
since we are implementing the first
generative method for fluid simulations
we decided to keep it very simple
thus our architecture is similar to the
generator of begin method
we notice that skip connections and wiki
value activation functions
help us to produce sharper results
additionally we can add linear
transformation layers
to intrinsically work with string
functions which i'm going to detail
later
so lastly i'm going to show how we
modify the loss functions
in order to fit fluid data
so as we train on velocity data from
fluid simulation
it is important to satisfy each curve
constraints
so one of those constraints is that
values are incompressible in this case
which means that the velocity fields are
divergence-free for simulation's
constant density
by taking curve on the output of the
metric
we can force a network to learn
corresponding stream function
of desired velocity output even without
crunch or stream function data
this guarantees divergence-free velocity
fields
however in case of liquid simulation
the velocity profile at the at the
interface is partially divergent because
the
air phase is obtained by velocity
extrapolation
so in that case we train the network
without divergence reconstructing
we show the difference between the
output train without and with divergence
reconstraint
in the closer views we can see that
accumulated divergence reduce the
amount of smoke density while attraction
so
left is just purely velocity base
middle is divergence free version and
the right is ground truth
the l1 loss function doesn't pin down
the derivatives
if the data is too smooth this can be
seen on the
the reconstruction plot
both left and right approximate the same
l1 loss compared to a base
the black which is represented in the
black line signal
first we increment the loss functions
to also match the jacobians of the of
the original simulation data
this is especially important for string
function fields
since we use the derivatives of those
to reconstruct velocities here
on the top part we see the
reconstruction without jacobian loss
which produces
noisy artifacts from gradients and on
the bottom image
with the jacobian laws
so here are results for parametrizable
scenes
so in this smoking scene our generative
model interpolates
inflow velocity the not presented in the
original data set
on the left we see direct crest policies
while on the right
issues cnn interpolation
interestingly we could see how our model
interplays on off-cycle position
notice that even though the middle scene
is not shown
during training it successfully
generates interpolations
so we compare it to the ground truth in
different time frames
and we can see that it still shows
plausible results
even compared to the ground truth
all method also can handle liquid
simulations which have discontinuous
boundaries across the
liquid air interface so on the left is
ground truth while on the right we show
our genitive approach
we demonstrate the work of liquid
dynamics are well preserved
here we interplace on the distance and
angle of
two liquid spheres and our model
reconstructs the new
in-between parameter point
we would like to highlight that the
interpolation quality depends on the
sampling density in training data set
from left to right there are 10 12
14 samples in liquid ball positions
notice that 10 positions the initial
leakage drop is not reconstructed so
well
however as we advance further in the
simulation to the time
that the liquid hits the beizing we
found out that
interestingly the matrix is more complex
structures and can
still recover the crown splash
accurately
our press is also able to interpolate
between non-trivial parameters such as
viscosity
the green liquids show correspondence to
the ground truth viscosities while
pink liquids show the sort of visuals of
interpolated
viscosities by our network
this is another interesting example as
we can interpolate on time
we can create a slow motion effect by
sampling
more or more velocity fields in time
axis
so what if we want to extend our
approach to
a more difficult sense to parameterize
our example of a scene with the
difficult parametrization is this moving
smoke scenario
we could parametrize the simulations by
the history of its source positions in
time
but this creates a large parametric
parametrization space that makes
the training unfeasible
so if you have no feasible
parameterization
one way we can do is to build a reduced
uh parameterization by
manual reduction for manifold learning
so one could employ linear dimensional
schemes like pca svd
however many subspace representation can
learn more about representative features
of the data manifold
therefore we chose an auto encoder
subspace representation this is common
option on the context of
machine learning algorithms
so in our setting the decoder is just
identical to our previous generative
model and the encoder
is just a decoder mirrored architecture
and below we show some examples of
consecutive latent codes
in time the issue now is that
the time information is diffused in
latent space
so for the given latent cause the time
denoted by the highlighted red voxels
first we need to know how to advance
time in the laden space
therefore we designed the novel latency
based integrator which helps
navigate how to go from the current
latent code
to the next one and then we construct
the corresponding velocity field and
which consists of
a fully connected neural network that
maps uh subsequently then cause
and yeah here it works like this again
so as your as a visual extended
parameterization
we could successfully handle new uh
source motion
that the network hasn't seen before
during the training
so here is our performance table
and as i mentioned earlier we could
achieve
up to 700 times speed ups compared to
the underlying
cpu surface and in terms of compression
ratio we could achieve like
more than 1000 uh
and when we compare to the famous
compression algorithm in a scientific
visualization called
floating point chip we also could much
better measures in terms of compression
ratio
and also in the errors
so of course there are some limitations
of our method
so the reconstructed data is too famous
so one remedy could be in
gaen so train with the discriminator but
it usually hallucinated high frequency
details so it's not physically plausible
and ghosting may happen if the data is
not sampled with
enough density and boundary conditions
introduce the discontinuities that might
leave the liquid particles hanging
and for the latent space integration it
can be also
improved and we just use a simple
multi-layer perception
so which might not be an optimal option
so in summary of the of this work
contribution was
uh we proposed a fast and plausible
approximation of parametrizable eulerian
fluid simulation with high compression
ratio
and also proposed to level latent space
integrator
and it could be suitable for games and
real-time virtual environments
and as a future work yeah we had to
handle some boundary conditions
and we can improve the latent space
integration for example with the lstm
and we can bypass the modeling by
directly reconstructing capture data
as well so that was the
brief overview of the our first work d
fluid
and there were two more follows to this
work one uh is uh frequency or
reconstruction of fluid simulations with
uh charted mattress and the second one
was the recently
presented at the simple german computer
animation
so titled latent space sub subdivision
so i'll just gonna give a very
quick brief overview of each work
so as i mentioned the default uh the
reconstruction quality
wasn't perfect so it basically shows two
smooth wizards
so in this work we try to improve the or
bringing back the high frequency details
while reconstructions
so the idea is that we try to persist
problem in a spectral domain
so for uh from training sample the
the parameter c and the u the velocity
field of c
we can fit this to reconstruct the
uh use c hat which is the g is the
generator the d fluid architecture
and we can take the free transform of
the
reconstructed velocity field also can do
the same thing on the
ground truth and then compare the
each band the the frequency of each band
by filtered by each
box filters for example
and then compare the
frequencies in each event and then yeah
so that was the basic idea because to to
bring the high frequency back so that we
can give more
uh impacts on the the high frequency
area
so the the free fourier loss was uh
basically can be constructed by the
magnitude comparison or phase or norm
but we just took the normal comparison
with the l1 loss
and this was the result of the d fluid
which is baseline
and this is the result of the this work
the follow-up
and this is ground juice maybe i can go
back again so baseline
and improve work and then this is ground
chest
so that was a brief overview of the
follow-up of the fluid
and and this is more direct
follow-up of the d fluid
so in this paper
we try to have more
stable and controllable integration in a
latent space
so the contribution is
basically provide the joint end-to-end
training
to allow the holistic view on both
temporal
and spatial components so within
d fluid we train the auto encoder
separately just to get the
spatial representation to compress
spatial representations and then train
the
the latent space integrator separately
for the time integration but in this
work we do the joint training
to give a holistic view on both sides
and also to be more generalized
we separate the we subdivide the latent
space
to be more physically informed
so they could be more generalized and
robust and stable
in a temporal prediction and also speed
ups as well
so this is kind of a schematic view like
the the right one the label no split
shows the
like uh show the latent space
uh trend laden space of uh which is
train on
density and velocity fields so if we fit
both informations to the auto encoder
and the laser and then we take a look at
the latent code
then the latent space has like a
diffused
information of both quantities but by
in this work by constraining for the
soft constraint on the latent space
we try to separate the
uh the spaces for storing the
quantities or its velocity and density
and we could have more structured
latent space in time and then it helps
for better and stable
temporal predictions so
last one is the
pca visualization of the network without
any constraint
and then b is the visualization of the d
fluid laden space and the
right one which shows much more
structured
latent lines
are the result of this work
so
here's uh the revert the visual readers
of this work
so it shows better predictions and in
terms of long-term predictions
the no split version which is the fluid
start to fail after
like certain like 300 frames for example
but the hours is much more
stable
here it shows like it now
allows some controllability on the
latent space we could
fit additional obstacle information in
the laden space
which wasn't uh able to be handled
in a previous version and this is a
visual of 3d
so
that was the first part of
our uh of this talk and the second part
i'd like to present some other work
about the
vortex extraction which is uh usually
done in a scientific visualization field
and this work is titled a robust
reference frame extraction from
unsteady to the vector fields with
convolutional networks
and presented at the eures last year
so the visualization process can be
commonly summarized to a four-step
procedure
the first we pre-process the raw data to
filter
unnecessary parts or fill out missing
parts by
smoothing or resampling or interpolation
then feature extraction will be followed
as
we dig out what we want to see
the next step is mapping and rendering
to match corresponding graphics
primitives to the extracted feature
and to obtain a final image
in recent years deep learning has been
quite successful in many computer vision
tasks
and today i'd like to show how deep
learning can
combine pre-processing and feature
extraction in one step for visualization
so in order to understand fluid dynamics
better we investigate the features or
patterns in vector fields
so in this talk the feature that we want
to take a look at is
vertices as seen in the video
vertices themselves are studied in many
different applications such as for
engine design
or blood flow analysis
the main challenge in these applications
is about how to extract vortices
in unsteady flow fields
a vertex is commonly understood as a set
of particles rotating
rotating around a common point or axis
if the flow is viewed in a correct
reference frame
here we show uh three different
reference frames to illustrate how they
affect the visual vertex extraction
on the left and right reference frames
by standing still and arbitrary movement
leads to the failure of vertex
extraction
while on the middle linearly translating
reference frame shields plausible
wizards
this dependence on the reference frame
is what makes
vortex extraction in unsteady flows
difficult
to avoid this problem we want methods
that
are invariant under reference frame
motions
a popular class of reference frame in
variance is called objectivity
which is the the invariance to a smooth
rotation and the translation of the
reference frame
on the right image we can see
translating reference frame while
rotating
now the question is how can we find
vertices objectively
the method that we take is to find the
reference frame in which
flow is steady the advantage of these
ways is that a standard techniques of
steady flow
become applicable such as critical
points searching 2d
or surgically high mass in 3d and the
search is formulated as an optimization
problem
so let's look a little bit closer at the
optimization problem
given is an unsteady flow v at position
x and time t
and we want to find the the parameters
of an objective reference frame
transformation
here q and c such that the time partial
is minimized meaning that the flow is
steady
and here we show a high level
illustration of this
optimization problem eventually
the time partial depends on of the
second order derivatives of
transformation parameters and it is
difficult to
robotically estimate if the data is
noisy
so as an example we show vortex core
lines resulting from linear reference
frame optimization method of skin
through error
on the left side horizontal plane
represent
a spatial domain while vertical axis
represents time axis
on the right side also shows our vertex
core lines from the same method but on
noisy data
on the top right corner we can see
incomplete vertex core lines compared to
the left side
this result implies that existing method
is sensitive to noise
by conditioning the neural network to
noise to
noisy inputs and resampling artifacts we
obtain numerically more stable
research than existing optimization
based approach
so in this paper we propose the first
convolutional network that can robustly
extract the optimal reference frame of
noisy unsteady flow by combining
filtering and extraction pipeline
in addition our second contribution is a
novel parametric flow mixture model for
a large collection of vector fields data
set which is typically required for
supervised learning
so now i'm going to illustrate the
overview of our method
our method takes the patches of unsteady
flow
and corrupted by noise and resampling
artifacts as an input
and infer the first and second order
derivative derivatives of
reference frame transformation
parameters
as we need a large number of vector
fields for supervised
learning we first synthesize the steady
flow
and transform it to unsteady flows with
a random transformation
then the degenerated with noise and
resampling artifacts then finally
performs
supervised learning next i'd like to
detail the
steady flow synthesis
so how do we generate steady flow fields
first
so if we have more feasible
parametrization
one way we can do is to do the reduce
parametrization by dimension reduction
for manifold learning as i mentioned but
one could employ
but however we're not aware of enough
real world data for learning this task
and we use a pairs of unsteady flow and
transformation parameters for training
but there is no ground truth parameters
in measured data
moreover these reconstruction approaches
require additional confidence for
physically plausible flows such as
divergence 3
first we propose a parametric mixture
model
for steady vector fields
since we mainly interested in vertices
we looked into fluid dynamics
literature and made the use of batista's
experimentally obtained
vertex model so you illustrate the
the tangential flow velocity
and uh for the rotationally symmetric
uh unit vertex and it takes rc
radius with the maximum velocity and
shape exponent as a parameter i'm just
gonna skip the details
so we show an example of the case that
the rcs1 and
ns2 top image is illustrated by
a line integral convolution with color
coded velocity magnitude
and the bottom is the plot of tangential
velocity field along
the radius so interestingly the tista's
profile contains other well-known vertex
models such as kaufman rankine and the
rambojim model for specific values of
n then based on batista's velocity
profile
we define a parametric model first for a
steady flow
with a critical point at t
uh divergence in a vertical motion
so in total each primitive has 8 degrees
of freedom
so we show some examples of different
parameterizations
all models represent a variety of
different flow structures
including vertices saddle and zinc and
source
lastly we define a mixture model of end
flow of
primitives since vector field patches
might contain multiple critical
points so our method
leads to a large number of different
vector fields
we found that the parameter space needs
to be restricted to physically plausible
flows
first we fit our model to
numerically simulated flows
so first with the extract optimal
reference frame to make flows
steady then we perform the
simulated annealing followed by gradient
descent to fit the
model parameters and the l1 distance
with the gradient is used as distance
function between velocity fields
so here we show a fitting example with
one flow component
component on the left and the reference
flow on the right
so we with only one model it doesn't
approximate the reference flow
perfectly
with two more or two more model
components it gets closer to the
reference flow
and again with three it shows a adequate
uh match to the numerical data
we have seen how well we can approximate
a single patch from
numerical data here we visualize the
approximation
error across the entire domain using the
heat maps of fitting residual in a
cylinder
filled with varying number of models and
the domain around the vertices is well
approximated with the three model
components
and we show that we can approximate flow
around vertices
furthermore we want to
generate more flows looks like a given
numerical flows
which share similar flow characteristics
for that region we approximate the
distribution of
individual parameters and it allows
sampling for
further steady vector fields patches
so going back to the overview of our
method
so far i have explained how we develop
our parametric mixture model for
steady vector field synthesis
in order to train our network that
recovers the reference frame
transformation
in a supervised manner we have to
generate unsteady vector fields with the
unknown ground truth transformation
for that we start from a steady vector
field and
transform it to unsteady fills with
random reference frame transformations
finally transformed unsteady fuels are
degenerated in order to
condition the network
so we consider two operations for
degeneration
the first one is additive uniform noise
and the second one is download sampling
as a distortion artifact
by using uh already generated unsteady
flows for training the network can
combine filtering and reference frame
reference frame extraction in one step
so next is supervised learning for
reference frame
extraction so we design our architecture
to efficiently handle
unsteady flow so instead of
using a sequence aware architecture like
lstm
we mainly used 3d convolution kernels
for feature extraction in spatial and
temporal domain
simultaneously and each convolution
block is
followed by batch normalization relative
activation layers
and two multi-layer perceptions are
added for final inference of parameters
so here are some some results of the
training and validation
firstly we have tested our model on the
test data which hasn't seen to the
network while training
we had compared our wizard with linear
optimization method of cancer error
and on the left the visual linear
optimization
doesn't match to the ground truth on the
right side
in the middle however our method
robustly handles
degenerated flows the numbers in
parenthesis are mean square error and we
obtain up to two orders of magnitude
lower errors than linear optimization
method
we also apply our network to unseen
numerical data to evaluate
how well the model is generalized
we used ceiling the flow with the
resolution of
640 by 80 by 5
and our network is trained on the window
size 16 by 16 by 5
so we slide the window by stride one and
yeah and we illustrate the single time
slice of the data and degenerated one
and in the closer view we can clearly
see the difference between
those flows
quantitatively our method
shows consistent robotness
on a varying scale of resampling
artifacts
here metric used the magnitude of time
partial of steady reference frame
the orange line is hours while blue line
is
from a linear optimization method
so this is the qualitative results
and also here this is uh
tested on the resampling artifacts
and also we showed a better result
compared to the
naive linear optimization method
so but the limitation
we
our network hasn't seen to the the
obstacle or boundary data
and our parametric mixture model also
can be pre
improved for better accuracy and didn't
extend to 3d yet so
there are some summaries so we utilize
the cnn to combine two steps of
featurelization pipeline in the
end-to-end manner
the filtering and the feature extraction
which it can be uh
can be difficult to handle by the the
knife
optimization method
so yeah that's i think
all for my side and thanks for your
attention and if you have any
questions i'm happy to answer to that